from its home in Paris Sam Rainsy says
he's determined to return to Cambodia
he's been in exile for much of the past
decade Raines he says he wants to gather
other opposition politicians from the
banned Cambodian national rescue party
to lead protests against Prime Minister
Hun Sen he says it's to restore
democracy to the country but as he
arrived at an airport in Paris and an
effort to return home this happened
I'm not allowed to vote with high
international slider right now
they said they have received from very
high up the instruction not to allow me
to board his deputy moose Akua it's one
of several opposition leaders who fled
from Cambodia fearing arrest she too
tried to return to Cambodia but was
detained after landing in Malaysia and
has since been released a day before her
news conference in Jakarta was
interrupted by the cambodian ambassador
to Indonesia but she's visited from
Cambodia she's a criminal
we have chosen to go back home to
Cambodia by land we have high hopes that
Thailand that is a chair of ASEAN would
be on the side of Cambodians Democrats
her party's acting leader Sam Rainsy has
been part of Cambodia's political fold
for decades he was the finance minister
under a unity government in the early
1990s before Hun Sen seized power in a
coup in 1997 reins he set up his own
opposition party but left Cambodia many
times to avoid government charges
against him Cambodia is trying to bully
all its neighbors to keep the cnrp
exhales out or to arrest them and send
them back we don't think that anybody's
gonna actually do Cambodia dirty work to
arrest people and actually deliver them
to homes and but our view is that the
cnrp officials like all Cambodians have
the right to return to their country Sam
Rainsy
says he's ready to return home and bring
an end to Prime Minister Hun Sen's
government and restore democracy in
Cambodia even if it means prison or
worse law Roberta Manley al Jazeera